et là en fait vous êtes emprisonné dans
votre propre corps c'est le fameux
looking room oui sauf que eux ils ont
les yeux ouverts tandis que les miens
sont fermées j'arrive même pas à ouvrir
une paupière rien
bonsoir
alors
être enterré vivant et l'une des pires
angoisses existentielles c'est ce qui a
failli vous arrivez en gel
dans le coma sur un lit d'hôpital vous
ressentiez et vous entendiez tout ce qui
se passait autour de vous mais tout le
monde vous croyez morte les médecins
envisagaient même de vous débrancher et
là vous avez versé une larme une larme
qui vous a sauvé la vie
[Musique]
en gel Ibis vous êtes né à Strasbourg le
25 mai 1952 petite dernière d'une
famille d'agriculteurs cinq frères et
soeurs vous dites nous sommes les
enfants de la terre enfance heureuse
alors préférant le travail aux études
très tôt vous prenez le chemin de
l'usine pour commencer à gagner votre
vie
de 16 ans vous rencontrez un garçon un
petit peu plus âgé que vous qui
s'appelle Ré
et quand vous montrez sa photo à une
voyante elle vous prédit que vous
épouserez un homme en uniforme et
effectivement vous épouserez en 1970 il
devient policier
alors avec Ray vous aurez une fille
quelques mois plus tard qui s'appelle
Cathy voilà alors vous travaillez dans
une usine de tricotage pendant plus de
20 ans et quand elle ferme j'ai
travaillé dans une usine qui fabrique
des chariots pour les supermarchés les
aéroports les hôpitaux et vous c'est
vous qui mettez les monnayeurs oui parce
que je pensais encore travailler deux
trois années avait avant ma retraite et
je me suis dit donc ça s'est présenté
alors en plus de ça vous faites du sport
la course à pied de la randonnée en
montagne de natation du vélo enfin à 57
ans vous étiez très en forme quand ça
vous est arrivé c'est là qu'un samedi
vous avez un léger mal de gorge et le
dimanche un gros coup de fatigue rien
d'inquiétant mais ce qui est quand même
très bizarre et votre soudain au bout de
l'ananas et bien se trouve une supportez
plus l'acidité de l'ananas
alors le 13 juillet 2009 en arrivant
dans le parking de l'usine où vous
travaillez vous ressentez un picotement
au bout des doigts
ça faisait très très mal d'avoir une
main
ensuite pareil si ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai jamais eu donc vous allez vous
allez quand même travailler
mais en fait c'est à peine au boulot que
vous ressentez un violon mal de tête et
bien tout vous êtes obligé de quitter
votre travail quelques heures après
avoir commencé et vous rentrez chez vous
je me suis dit il faut que je rentre
parce que sinon j'aurais trop peur de
plus comme pouvoir conduire
vous dites c'est comme si ma tête était
serrée dans un casque trop petit et le
casque continué à rétrécir je pleurais
c'était plus supportable
le SAMU vous arrivez à l'hôpital piqûre
comprimé examen ponction lombaire ils
comprennent rien à ce qui se passe
pourtant votre état empire vous passez
rapidement à un raidissement puis à une
espèce de de paralysie et autour de vous
tout devient
pas pour eux cotonneux comme un
brouillard j'avais plus de réflexe les
jambes je parlais de plus en plus
doucement vous n'arrivez plus à manger
ni à boire à ce moment-là et bientôt
vous commencez à avoir des difficultés
pour pour respirer quoi enfin je
m'éteignais tout doucement
sans trop m'en rendre compte
alors les médecins décident de vous
placer en coma thérapeutique pendant un
ou deux jours et là quand vous reprenez
conscience tout est noir autour de vous
noir complet je me demandais ce qui
s'était passé alors j'attendais une
respiration rapide à côté de vous vous
savez pas si c'est un être humain un
animal en fait c'est le respirateur
artificiel qui vous maintient en vie et
qui vous écrase le torse
qui m'écrasait c'est pour ça que je
pensais qu'il y avait eu quelque chose
s'effondrait et que vous êtes piégé sous
les gravats et qu'à côté de vous il y a
quelqu'un qui respire fort en fait
et à part ça vous vous sentez en forme
vous sentez rien d'autre voilà alors
vous ne le savez pas encore en gel ne
vous avez repris conscience alors que
votre corps est toujours inerte et là en
fait vous êtes emprisonné dans votre
propre corps c'est le fameux looking
room oui sauf que eux ils ont les yeux
ouverts tandis que les miens sont fermés
j'arrive même pas à ouvrir une paupière
alors vous entendez les gens qui
viennent vous voir
très consciemment en fait il y en a qui
font des prières qui me parlent il y en
a qui disent mais il faut que tu te
réveilles mais j'ai l'impression que je
sens toutes les présences même celles
qui parlent pas je ça me fait du bien
alors quand vous entendez votre mari est
vous frémissez vous tremblez vous lui
parlez un régime je n'ai rien
mais que vous criez mais aucun son ne
sort de votre bouche
vous dites faut vraiment que je leur
envoie un signe mais vous n'avez pas le
moyen de le faire en fait non je peux
rien faire alors un jour vous recevez la
visite d'une voisine qui vous dit
Angèle même dans le coma tu es belle
et là vous comprenez que tout le monde
vous croit dans le coma en fait
j'étais alors psychologique évidemment
d'être enfermé dans son propre corps il
y a aussi pas mal de tortures physiques
a commencé par le nettoyage des sinus
très très douloureux en m'injecter de la
bétadine dans le nez et une autre
personne mettez un petit inspirateur au
fond de la gorge tout derrière et
aspirer et agiter ça
c'est
astrophe
aussi c'est que c'est la musique c'est à
dire qu'une infirmière croyant bien
faire mais de la musique dans votre
chambre alors au début ça vous soulage
évidemment je me suis dit un super oui
ça s'éteint un moment donné ah que c'est
triste ici dans cette chambre et puis on
rallume
en fait de tout plein de choses c'était
de la variété mais ça n'arrêtait plus
alors pour s'assurer que que vous êtes
bien morte parce que tout le monde vous
vous croit morte on vous fait le fameux
test du téton parce qu'en fait le test
du téton n'importe qui qui est encore un
peu de vie saut en l'air quoi on vous
prend un petit peu
le geste normalement on fait si on est
en vie
et moi j'ai pas bougé rien même pas une
paupière donc ça c'est pour eux c'est
que ça voulait dire c'est vraiment la
fin oui enfin bon mon cœur battait
toujours mais quand il faisait les
nettoyages des sinus un moment donné
j'ai entendu une femme qui disait elle a
trois soins par jour on va lui faire
qu'un parce que toute façon elle va
clamser elle a entendu ça d'un médecin
du grand chef qu'il a dit alors la seule
consolation pour vous à ce moment-là
c'est de vous dire comme j'ai demandé à
être incinéré après ma mort je
n'essaierai pas de gratter le couvercle
angoisse vous aviez dit à votre mari que
si vous mourriez vous vouliez donner vos
organes à d'autres gens et et là
évidemment à chaque fois que quelqu'un
rentre dans la chambre vous pensez qu'on
va vous prélever le cœur ou le foie
alors là vous commencez à entendre
parler de vos obsèques
ça c'est mon mon mari qui a subi tout ça
mais heureusement Ray votre mari annonce
au médecin qu'il refuse de vous
débrancher
pourquoi il a fait ça
un combat inconsable le bout de 4 jours
que c'était la fin alors le temps passe
et un jour c'est votre anniversaire de
mariage
Ré et Cathy sont avec vous et votre
fille vous dit ne t'en fais pas ma
petite maman je prends soin de papa et
là vous êtes submergé par l'émotion
enfin une larmée sortie
enfin le premier organe qui a fonctionné
et là votre fille dit maman a réagi à la
pleurer et le médecin dit non pas du
tout c'est c'est du gel qu'on leur met
pour que les paupières ne se collent pas
[Musique]
et un peu plus tard les yeux tout d'un
coup les yeux se sont verts vous dites
c'est le plus beau anniversaire de
mariage que j'ai vécu c'est certain
alors voilà ensuite la rééducation sera
lente et terrible parce qu'il faut
apprendre à respirer à manger à parler à
marcher c'est de trop cérébral qui était
atteint et puis
ça débranche tout comme l'ordinateur
réapprendre même avaler combien de temps
pour revenir dans l'état où vous êtes
aujourd'hui
pour être vraiment debout
au presque une année
s'appelle la maladie de Bickerstaff
alors c'est une dégradation soudaine de
la myéline due à une réponse
disproportionnée du système immunitaire
suite à une infection mais heureusement
la myéline se régénère naturellement
dans votre milieu n'est revenu ce qu'il
faut expliquer aux gens c'est que la
myéline c'est une substance qui isole
est-ce que je veux dire aux gens qui se
droguent en prenant de la cocaïne c'est
que la cocaïne ça bouffe la myéline on
peut le dire aux gens parce que
il y a quand même des questions qui
restent en suspens pourquoi pendant
votre commande aviez-vous aucun signe
vital pourquoi votre encéphalogramme est
resté plat alors que vous étiez
consciente et pourquoi vous n'avez pas
réagi au fameux test du téton comme ça
c'est des c'est des questions qui sont
sans réponse aujourd'hui ça
savent pas
ils connaissent pas trop non plus cette
maladie parce que moi j'étais là
quinzième dans le monde à voir cette
maladie
je sais que maintenant il y en a déjà 60
c'est à cause de ça aussi le livre que
qu'on peut vivre et se remettre bon
c'est pas forcément ça marche peut-être
pas tout le temps mais au moins il y a
une preuve moi je trouve très belle
c'est à dire la façon dont vous en
parlez je trouve ça très beau avec
dignité et que la leçon vous en tirez
l'espoir l'ouverture sur les autres
voilà je trouve ça très émouvant je vais
revenir sur le punk c'est au fond moi on
vous écoutant
9h sur under c'est à dire ne lâcher
jamais il y a toujours un espoir c'est
vrai pour tout et surtout
garder espoir quoi qu'il arrive très
beau mot de la fin merci merci de votre
témoignage et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu